[Music]
good to have you here today Scott's so
nice to meet you thanks for doing this
thank you so much for having me Richards
it's awesome pleasure to be here I I
welcome you to the northern Arizona of
Los Angeles this as close as we can get
to your to your training grounds but
it's pretty nice up here so I appreciate
you making the truck of course thank you
thank you so much for having me yeah of
course what I really want to talk about
before anything is the showrunners
podcast all right let's do it but we
could just like yeah movie was a dive
right in man I mean that's why I started
the podcast all right no I like talking
about movies there it's a fun run
conversation which is where I spend most
of my like social time with friends and
stuff uh-huh and I was like I'm got free
time I would like to kind of watch
movies in a more like structured way and
I was just like let's just do it and I
talked to a friend of mine who owns a
bird I guess not maybe not owns but runs
a running web site uh-huh sidious mag
and I was like hey javascript shop is
yeah and I was like hey can I have my
own podcast I just want to talk about
movies with my friends and he was like
yeah and the show is perfect I don't
know dear you think about anything but
running
I know exactly that's right I'm one
dimensional yeah yeah no I love it I
think it's so cool that you're doing
that and I would be delighted to just
talk about movies and nothing else the
whole time if that's what you want to
talk about you must be tired about
talking about Boston and all that you
know we can mention it here and there I
guess yeah we'd love to hear your takes
on the new Tarantino movie oh we can do
a whole deep dive on ones yeah I'm ready
to go like you yeah it's sort of
rewatchable with runners that's yes very
much so it's a you know I don't want to
take too much credit for the idea but
it's very much a rip off oh yeah I love
that show yeah it's great a huge fan of
it so I thought it was super cool that
you're doing that and I think it's cool
that that you live this full life like
you're you're at the you know the very
tip of Elite marathoning
and and yet you still carve out time to
develop your interest with this podcast
and writing the book and you know all
the other things that you do so I'm
interested I guess first of all and just
hearing
like that informs your rut like I
presume that having all of those other
interests is super important in terms of
you just being a happy person so that
you can perform at your best whereas
certain people might look at that as a
distraction especially going into olynyk
year yeah I think so for me it was very
strange for me to go from a college
setting where I was very intellectually
stimulated to a professional running set
setting where there's really no
structured way to flex your mind and for
maybe a year I really like leaned into
that and I just like binge watched the
office in Parks and Rec and 30 rock a
hundred times and then after I don't
have anyone to talk about yeah and after
maybe a year I was like I gotta like I
got to find something else to fill the
time and that's now at this point I've
I'm doing it in a way that I feel
comfortable like sharing and having like
structured interests and making it more
as like an outward thing as opposed to
me just reading a book
yeah inside yeah well there's only I
mean I I would imagine your training
schedule put you at somewhere around 25
or 30 hours a week which still leaves a
lot of time right or well there's all
the extra stuff on top of that I mean it
is a full-time job but they're still
down time yeah I would say it's if you
include napping maybe 25 hours a week I
it's a it's a soft 25 hours and it's not
like watching movies is strenuous by any
means I'm not going out and doing
Crossfit in my spare time right and
that's not I can watch a movie and
recover at the same time so it was kind
of a way to like use my spare time in a
way that felt mentally productive yeah
well getting my head around you and your
life in your career in preparing to talk
to you today most of the media coverage
about you was kind of right post Boston
so which we're going to get into but I'm
interested in kind of where you're at
now as you know some time has elapsed
and you're preparing for trials and you
got to race this weekend coming up
like where's your head at how are you
feeling what is your you know sort of
mental perspective as we're like what a
hundred and ninety hundred and eighty
days out of trials at this point yeah
I'm not sure I I don't count it out good
for ya
I'm yeah so physically we're doing a
segment where I'm not gonna marathon
this fall mm-hmm
we decided to get away from the marathon
after running Boston and what's that
what is that decision about it was so I
ran New York Marathon last year in
Boston this year and that was a whole
year of marathoning and the thing about
the marathon is it's very hard and very
specific and so you don't really have
time to do some stuff that don't really
lend themselves to the marathon but it's
still important to work on so shorter
tempos speed stuff so for the long term
that will be helpful but we kind of
needed to find a place to do it before
the Olympic Trials segment really
started and we really got going on
really marathon specific stuff so
physically that's kind of where I'm at
I'm doing a lot of workouts that I don't
feel really comfortable in like I'm not
they're not the workouts that are really
my bread and butter but will be
important for the Olympic Trials in a
few months and then are particularly
important as we build into the segments
where we really get ready for the trials
yeah you know mentally things haven't
changed for me I am very much a believer
that like the best way to accomplish
goals down the line is to do really well
at what you're doing right now so
whatever is on my schedule I just try to
do as well as I can in that and I have
faith in like my coach and the people
around me that if I do kind of what they
say as well as I can right now the
larger puzzle will come together down
the line right it feels like you've
really part of your your mindset game is
to divest yourself of thinking too hard
or much about the preparation like you
really trust your coach and you let him
make those decisions and that frees up
some kind of head space for you to just
be you yeah I think that's right that's
probably accurate and it's just
generally being like
one of the kind of buzzwords and sports
and business and everything right now is
like process-oriented and for me what
that means being process-oriented
means like a focusing on day by day and
be not judging my performances down the
line against other people mm-hmm
they're based on what I feel like I can
do and whether or not I got the most out
of myself mm-hmm and so yeah right now
it's just it's been about getting the
most out of myself every day and whether
or not rice a hard day or an easy day
Soviet you know I heard you speaking
maybe it was with Chris you were talking
about what you respected and kept chogi
and and perhaps you know some of the
other East African runners and one of
the things is like they don't worry
about all that stuff like whether they
changed the course or or you know all
the kind of externalities that can throw
people off their game like they seem to
dutchess that's just you know water
under the bridge to them like they're so
focused on what they're doing so when I
hear you say that it sounds like you've
adopted your your striving to adopt that
kind of mentality yeah hopefully where
it's I think it's the sport is a lot
more simple a lot simpler when you just
don't worry Melissa it's just running
realistically like yeah everyone wants
to make it this big complicated thing
but it's a pretty simple thing uh-huh
everyone can go for a run and you don't
have to think about like all these
tactics all the time and don't have to
worry about the courses or the hills or
the turns or the weather like it's just
running like just get out of your own
way is kind of my own Mike Ryan title
Montrose Boston there's a lot there's a
bigger spotlight on you now well you're
not you're not as under the radar as you
were a year ago two years ago right so
do you is do you feel that or do you do
your best to insulate yourself from all
of that my hope is that it it doesn't
change anything the fact that I'm in a
bigger spotlight and I think mentally it
hasn't changed anything because like I
have I think I'm viewed as being very
confident now but I was confident on
April 14th to like yeah I didn't
necessarily surprise myself
that I ran that well in Boston I kind of
knew that that was possible and so it's
not like
I have to make a change I knew I was
capable of it then and now it's just
it's on the it actually happened but I
kind of believed it was gonna happen
beforehand right yeah but at Boston you
were like what was your bib number like
28 yeah like that way so you know if you
were to make a surge or try to do
something spectacular there was the
chance that they would let you go I mean
we're gonna tell that whole story but
you could have done a little bit of a
sneak move that you probably can't get
away with now yeah maybe I'm not really
sure all eyes on you yeah probably not
yeah maybe I could still get away with
her boss and I have no idea
um you know meb one after he was very
very good already had done some great
things so there's chance I don't really
know but yeah I don't really I'd hope
that I don't change based on the fact
that I have a spotlight on me now yeah
and and I also heard you say shortly
after Boston that you know that it would
be a mistake for you to alter your
training too much like this is what
worked this is what got me to this place
like let's kind of stay on this path and
not you know make some rash decisions
about changing up too many things
leading into 2020 that still yes
absolutely
I think that's probably the biggest
mistake people make is like they have
this sort of breakthrough performance
and like well it's just push the
envelope let's just keep pushing pushing
pushing but really the way we got to
this point was by picking and choosing
when we were gonna really push and then
also just hitting singles you know we
just trying to get on base trying to do
well at everything we did and
occasionally you swing big and try to
have a really big day whether that's in
a workout or like Boston in a big race
but um yeah I think it would be easy to
get really results focused but again I
wanted to stay like this is the process
that got us here let's just keep getting
better at this and I just we just have
faith that the results will come right
well let's work our way up to this so
you start off you start out as
essentially a cross-country protege in
Colorado right sure standout high school
cross-country runner then you go to
Portland you run into a
and you are a standout but it wasn't
like you were winning tons of races like
lots of twelfths and fifteenth's and
things like that I guess you got injured
in your senior year yep
so perhaps you know you weren't able to
show what you were truly capable of at
the time but it wasn't like oh here's
the next new face of you know American
distance running yeah is that fair no
absolutely I you know I mean I don't
think I'd be going like speaking out of
turn when I said I signed for $0 my
first my salary at the start was $0 and
I signed my first contract in my
girlfriend's mini-cooper with a boot on
my foot right it was a very inauspicious
like way to start a professional running
career ha and not at all how I had ever
dreamed of it well I love how the book
opens up with this email exchange yeah
you know we're basically you're trying
to you know you're trying to get on this
team you're trying to get on the
northern Arizona team and Ben is like
Ben Rosario the coach is like nah I
don't think so yeah yeah I'm not sure
and it took a little jockeying and
back-and-forth and a word put in by
Elaine's husband to even get you know
get your name on that roster yeah
absolutely I'm super grateful for Steve
to see you for going to bat for me
because he absolutely didn't didn't need
to Steve Edwards Jillian's husband yeah
and I think probably when I emailed Ben
he was like yeah I'd like this guy guess
this guy's fine but at that point like
you know we had Ben Bruce was running in
his prime he was running like 1330s in
the 5k and eight 20s and the steeple and
Matt Yana would just run 101 45 and I
was kind of asking it's like can I
please come and like I'll figure out a
way to pay for things you don't have to
pay me anything and Ben was like this
guy really gonna be good enough and yeah
I mean I I'm just happy to have it have
had a chance really so how does it work
like when you're graduating from college
and you're a standout performer and
you're trying to get you know in on one
of these squads like yeah there really
is a gate right like you have to impress
the coach or you have to be invited like
how does it you know what how does that
work for somebody who knows nothing
about like elite running yeah the
business structure for elite running is
what like golf in the sense that we like
have sponsors
and there's prize money it's just way
less whatever you see on the PGA Tour
just way less than that and it kind of
depends on the king yeah shocking of
course yeah it kind of depends on how
good you are so if you are good enough
where you're kind of lighting the world
on fire in college people will come to
you mm-hmm and if you're in my position
I kind of felt like I had to go to
coaches and I was very lucky to have
been introduced to schlenz husband Steve
Edwards and he kind of gave me enough
guidance to be like this is some people
you could look at and what I did was
just went to every professional running
team's website that I could find and
emailed as many coaches as I could find
their contact info uh-huh and then then
got back to me and I was fortunate
enough that he was like took enough of
an interest in me to fly me down to
Flagstaff and I got to meet the team and
I don't think I wasn't like a huge risk
you know he didn't have to do like
designate any money to me at all but
he's basically like you can come on that
come if you work really hard you can run
well enough to earn a salary mm-hmm and
that's I mean that's kind of how it
happened I just put out as wide a net as
I could and when Ben got back to me I
knew that was kind of where I wanted to
be
I clicked really well with Ben Rosario
my coach and that was that I moved
Flagstaff in I mean I guess it would be
almost four years ago today yeah yeah
what is it that Ben was doing or that
was you know indicative of like you know
his coaching ability like what was
happening in northern Arizona that
caught your fascination like I was gonna
I mean it sounds like you were emailing
everybody but yeah you know what is
specific to that program that makes it
so unique and excellent yeah we the team
had signed with Hoke onaona which we're
still with now Hoka and nasally as like
a title sponsor earlier in the year and
that was kind of a big thing that caught
my eye because a lot of these groups
they don't have any funding mm-hmm and
even though it wasn't necessarily
getting paid there is like an
infrastructure and a prestige that comes
with having a title sponsor so that was
one thing and then I was really
really drawn to Ben's confidence and
Ben's like professionalism like he was
absolutely 100% all-in as a coach it was
like a full-time job for him and that's
even though there are quote-unquote
professional teams
that's not something you find all the
time there are a few professional
full-time coaches and there are a lot of
people who are like coaching after work
isn't he like a professor though also
doesn't he teach in Provo or something
like that
no sorry that's Jared ward oh yeah Jared
yeah no worries so when you show up do
you have to get like a part-time job or
like how do you make ends meet when
you're just beginning yeah so I worked a
ton flagstaff if for those who haven't
been there don't know it's not really a
great place to find like part-time job
and it's especially not a great place if
you say well yeah I can't come to work
anytime between 8:00 in the morning and
11:00 and a couple times during although
like in the evening I'll be gone from
3:00 to 5:00 and I need to nap yeah and
I need a nap and I can't come on
Thursday nights because I want to go
that's when we go to the weight room you
should move to Los Angeles there's lots
of people like that yeah
every actors schedules something along
those lines yeah so I I mean basically I
just made a resume and hand it out a
bunch of places and but I always made
sure to put like running first and I
worked a ton over the summer before I
moved to Flagstaff and basically just
burned through burned through my savings
like pretty quickly and I was fortunate
enough to run very well at the end of
the year and basically do enough to earn
a salary starting January first and then
reign well enough to kind of earn raises
throughout the year in my career right
well yeah like having to bootstrap that
yeah dream you know what I mean it was
pretty stressful I mean there were times
when my card got declined like and I
just like well I guess I'm not buying I
guess I'm not like I guess I'm not
buying his groceries like I'm gonna go
home and yeah like I got another like
another like living stipend coming in a
couple days so I guess that's when I'll
go get groceries it's so romantic
oh it was amazing your dream yeah so
there you are I mean one of the things
well first of all Steve in his email to
bed
is like listen you know this guy's a
marathoner you hadn't run a marathon yet
but he saw that in you you know bird
bones or whatever but he's got some
strength on him he's like perfectly
suited for this so there was a sense
that you you know were well-suited for
that discipline before you'd even ever
tried it so when you went to Flagstaff
was that the idea like I'm gonna step it
up and move to the marathon not right
off the bat but that was quite clearly
where I was going to have the most
success and it was just kind of a
question as to how long until I'm ready
to make a responsible jump to the
marathon as opposed to just jumping
right in right because I had a
qualifying time for the Olympic Trials
which were gonna be in February so I'm
running the half right yeah so I could
have gone straight to the marathon in
February 2016 but we kind of decided to
push that back and just be like let's
get miles under our belt let's get
comfortable in some of these long
workouts before we go 100% all in on the
marathon and we ended up doing that I
was still very young for yeah going to
the marathon at least for American
marathon yeah I mean that's one of the
things that's pretty unique about you is
that traditionally it's many years later
when when the elite runner kind of steps
it up to that distance and you made that
jump much sooner than most people
which puts you like now you know what
are you 27 now sometimes yeah yeah 27 I
mean that's really young you know yeah I
mean and three only three marathons
under your belt yeah and I mean I think
I'm kind of entering my prime physically
you know from probably 28 to 32 is when
you probably have all the tools you
haven't lost the fast twitch fibers but
you're probably not as injury risk but
you can you've run enough miles to be
really good and we're kind of with the
opinion that you should be running your
best event when you're at your
physically most capable right and so
maybe I could train really hard for a
spring and run sub 1330 on the track or
something like that in the 5k and hey I
have no interest in doing that and B I
would I'm better at the marathon so I
think it's important
to be doing what you're best at when
you're going to be the best at running
in general yeah and I think there's
still so much room for improvement
because you are still relatively new to
it and you're young you have your speed
you can handle you could probably handle
volume more than you know an older
person you're gonna be less injury prone
so when you look at that jump that you
made from going to 12 to 200 209 that
seems crazy but like you're still
developing as a runner and now here you
are going into Olympic year with another
year under your belt like that's pretty
exciting
yeah and I mean I sure hope there's
still more to gain that'd be that'd be
huge but um yeah I mean I'm very excited
very optimistic about the Olympic year
and I'm I feel like we're in a good spot
not only physically but also like
situationally I feel very comfortable
with the people around me and with what
like the routines we've carved out and
you know been in particular but we've
also got a really good weight training
staff in Weston AJ Greg who are our
strength coaches and Kairos and good
massage therapist so I feel very very
prepared I guess for the next six or
seven months or whatever it is too much
miles so your big coming-out party was
Boston I mean you'd already
youdon't you distinguished yourself in
New York and in Frankfurt you what do
you get and you got 7th in New York
right at 212 and then you were in
Frankfurt the year before that and got
9th also running 212 so you know in the
in the marathon world people were taking
notice and certainly knew who you were
but America learned to embrace you in
Boston America being very very niche
America well I mean listen you know a
lot of people watch the Boston Marathon
you don't know that much about elite
marathon running and when you took the
lead and they're like who's this guy you
know suddenly you're you're the topic of
conversation so let's spend a little
time talking about Boston sure I mean
because that was such a such an
extraordinary incredible performance and
I've heard you say going into that that
you knew you were capable of going under
210 and and you had a lot of confidence
going into it but that's different from
being in the mix of it and and sort of
leading the race at certain points like
are you like like how do you think about
that looking back on it now because the
interviews that I listen to and read
were right after that and I would
imagine that you know that experience is
settled in and maybe you have a little
bit more perspective on it now yeah
definitely
one thing I I don't think I did a good
job of communicating immediately after
the race was like when I led I was kind
of shocked and I not shocked I took a
moment to like appreciate it I was like
oh my god I'm leading the Boston
Marathon yeah like I took a moment to
let that soak in and like this is such
an amazing experience but it's not like
I went to the lead just to say that the
guy went to the lead a number of time
and to get my TV time man yeah I wanted
to lead with a purpose and with the goal
of like dropping people and making
people hurt and with like an agenda
initiative to get up to really push the
pace and I did I mean I took the lead at
for the first time seriously I like 16
miles and I was in and out of the lead
until like 22 and when I took the lead
at 16 there was a group of probably 25
people and when I got over the top of
Heartbreak Hill at 21
there was eight so I I don't think I
communicated the fact that I really
pushed I didn't just go to the lead to
be there there was a point and I mean at
this point after the race
I've kind of like let that sink in where
it's like yeah I'm really strong like I
can just kind of do that and feel really
comfortable up front as opposed to
getting up there and being really
nervous and right out of freaking out
yeah yeah do I really belong up yeah
yeah maybe I've overextended myself
absolutely well my sense from reading up
on this is that you were mannan ish
eiated if you were watching it you think
you're putting in these surges trying to
you know you know create a lead or
whatever but you were kind of sticking
to your own plan of what you wanted to
do and the surges in the regressions
were really a reflection of what the
pack was doing yeah
and not really what you were doing yeah
especially going up the the Newton Hills
so when you do take a right turn at 17
and a half miles and that's when the
hill is like really start and the
favorites and leaders they would push
really hard on the uphills and they're
these kind of rest bits in between the
hills where it was unclear whether they
were catching their breath or whether
they just wanted to slow it down for a
different reason and I would let myself
slip to the back of the group when they
were running hard up the hill and then
when we'd get over the top of the hill
and we'd have the flat section I would
just keep running the same rhythm so I'd
pick it up in pace because we were
running flat or downhill but I would
find myself going back to the front and
really dragging these people along
mm-hmm and that was mostly just me
trying to do the best thing for me it
wasn't like a huge tactical move to try
to break things open it was just like
the best way for me to get from here to
the top of these hills is to run one
really hard even pace right one of the
things you've talked about is the
difference between good and fast like
there's there's running fast but there's
also running good which is more about
racing right like how do you put in a
good performance amongst the group and
so when you're heading into Boston you
have a race plan this is what you know
what I think I can execute you've got it
all locked in but then you're in the
pack and things are happening and you've
got to adjust to what other people are
doing like how much of that plays into
spontaneous adjustments that you're
making or are you just like I'm running
my thing like I'm not paying attention
to any of these people like are you
reactive or responsive or are you just
within yourself I think at my best in
Boston I was I was within myself and not
worrying about the pace I mean I didn't
take a split the whole race like a mile
split the only way I was keeping track
of how fast free running was I'd look at
the clock every mile and I would just
take a note how many seconds under five
minute pace we were uh-huh and then once
we got to the hills at like 16 I stopped
looking at the clock completely until 25
or so you probably know yourself well
enough to know like you know like oh
that was that you probably knew your
pace just intuitively yeah mostly the
feel of it I wouldn't say I had like a
really firm grass
what the number was but I did know what
it was supposed to feel like and there
was a couple parts in the race where the
pack would surge and I would kind of get
left behind like most notably from like
12 to 14 there's this big surge in the
group and all of a sudden that was like
20 seconds back and at that point I was
thinking I was I wasn't within myself I
was thinking a lot about the pace it's
the amount about the numbers I was
thinking a lot about the people who are
running away from me and that was my
worst stretch of the race and once we
kind of got to this big downhill and I
was like okay just letting my legs flow
now I'm gonna let it turn over I kind of
got into this I guess you'd call it like
flow state where things didn't really
hurt and I was just kind of my legs were
moving without me really having to push
them mm-hmm that was my best stretch in
the race was after I got out of my own
head and got out of my own way and just
let myself go to what I felt like I
could do yeah well that takes a level of
maturity you know it'd be easier to just
freak out and go oh my god like I got a
I got a pick it up or I'm gonna lose
contact with the group right and get
outside of what you know what your plan
is because you're reacting yeah I'm I
hope so I hope I was mature for such a
young man yeah I mean it will only had
done to two other marathons up to that
point yeah that's a tribute to you and
like you know the work that you did with
your coach and the confidence that you
had going into going into the race how
much like what what is going on like
when you're part of that pack like are
people talking to each other like is
there jockeying like what is the
strategy that you kind of witness
unfolding amongst the leaders like I
think it's interesting for you know most
people that are listening of this our
casual runners at best you know I think
everyone would be super interested in
knowing like what is it what is it like
like our people talking [ __ ] to each
other or they like get out of my way or
is there any of that going on or what
does it feel like there's not a ton of
talking [ __ ] occasionally like people
will like say if it's a really crowded
pack there'll be some bumping right and
then there'll be some chirping people
don't necessarily care for that it's a
huge wide road you don't need to be all
over each other right there's some
etiquette yeah like give people some
birth mm-hmm but I mean for the most
part there are little like little mind
games you can see people playing like
if you've got a good tangent someone's
coming up on the inside you can kind of
squeeze them out mm-hmm
but for me I try to just stay out of all
of that I just I don't wanna I don't
need to worry about anyone else I just
want to do the best that I can do and
the more I get sucked into what other
people are doing the worse the end
result ends up being I think there was
one point where he took like you went
way wide of the group I can't remember
what that was like you had a better you
had a better like angle on the course
and everyone else and you were just kind
of completely separated from everyone
yeah that happens kind of quite a bit
for whatever reason I mean part of it is
that when you live in America you it's
easy to get to Boston so most of us who
had seen live in America saw the course
at some point but for whatever reason
the East Africans generally aren't great
at running tangents whether it's that
they haven't seen the course before or
that they just don't know where they're
where the race is going or whatever
they'll almost always be on the wrong
side of the road or they'll stay in the
middle of the road when it turns coming
up and it's kind of it's almost baffling
like some of these guys in the race have
run Boston like six or seven times
uh-huh and it's like we're coming up to
a big right-hand turn guys like I'm
their way obviously the right side you
obviously want to be over here so I
think it was mostly like I just had
faith that I knew where I was going and
I knew what the best plan was yeah so at
some point so you take the league you're
you're up in the front and the group's
getting smaller and smaller you take the
lead what is it like it at around like
19 or 20 or something like yeah there
are a couple spots where I got on the
front yeah and at that point you must be
thinking I mean you're strong finisher
right like yeah I've been closing
workouts really won't Lee just bust a
move here and break away like these
people aren't really expecting me to do
anything like that but that ended up not
being the case right so walk me through
like how that last part of the race went
yeah I think I like 19 was when the
group was really down to like eight
people huh and I was kind of sitting on
the back going up like the last of the
Newton Hills Heartbreak Hill and you
know you mentioned before I was bid
number 28 and in Boston they they go at
by PR so I had 28 the 28th
PR 212 there were 29 men in the Olympic
in the mili field so on paper I should
have been down there and up ahead of me
is like 2 4 7 8 and I remember thinking
like the slowest guy in this group has
runs 6 minutes faster than me over the
course of a marathon and then I was kind
of like you know what it doesn't matter
right now there's nothing I can do about
that at this moment and as we got up the
very last hill just like I had at every
other hill I got over the top and I
accelerated off the crest of the hill
and all of a sudden I found myself in
the front and for like a split second I
was like you know if I go really really
hard right now maybe they'll kind of let
me go maybe they'll think like we can
pull him back later and this is my best
shot and I pushed pretty hard for like
50 or 60 meters and they came right with
me it was too late they were going to be
covering everything and so we get to 22
miles which is kind of a hard mile and
you take a left turn at Cleveland Circle
you're going down Beacon Street now and
right as we take that turn seven guys
start running way faster than I'm
capable yeah like they just are
hammering this is like you're you're
Dennis christopher moment in Breaking
Away oh yeah you know yeah I just visit
you know envisioning that scene where
all the Italians roll up and you know
he's by himself and they you know they
they put the the pump in his spokes and
he goes down yeah that was one of my big
quips was with that movie it was like
how did they how did he even get up with
these guys they had a gap they should've
just use team tactic stayed away but um
yeah yeah other than the bike spoke in
the wheels it was basically the same
thing yeah it was like they just started
cranking and I just couldn't hang and
fur like maybe 30 seconds I threw myself
a little pity party or a second [ __ ] I'm
not good enough today like I'm not gonna
be able to hang like I ran 22 great
miles and I was like no you know what
like [ __ ] that like I'm having a great
day today like we're getting focused
again and it hurt a lot like I was in a
ton of pain but if I when I just got
really really dialed in and just making
it to the next mile marker getting next
to the next K I could kind of get back
into that rhythm and I went back to like
my power phrases the stuff that I'd been
doing every time
got really hard in practice which was
like this one jay-z song that I like is
[ __ ] with me you know I got it so I kept
saying that over over in my head
uh-huh and kept reminding myself to just
keep the pedal down keep the pedal down
and eventually I caught up to seventh
place moved into seventh and got up the
there's like a tiny little hill leading
into 25 at Boston at 25 miles it feels
like a freaking Mountain right it feels
awful and I look to the clock and I saw
one mile to go I needed like a 450 to
break 209 and I was like all right we're
going for it and I pushed basically as
hard as I could for like 600 meters and
then you do this little underpass and
push down it started going up it and my
legs just went they just weren't just
like I got kicked in the nuts and get up
to the top of the underpass right on a
hare furred a little bit of a hill left
on Boylston and the Uni got like 600
yards and I still thought maybe I had a
shot so I like as you can see that
finish line for him quite just yet I'd
probably was still reading like 207 or
something yeah and so I was just
hammering I was still like it's like I'm
gonna go deeper I can go deeper like
keep pushing yourself keep pushing
yourself you can take more pain you can
take more pain and it wasn't until like
maybe 60 or 70 yards when it's like I'm
not gonna not gonna go under t1i and I'm
not gonna catch anyone at that point I
kind of let myself really enjoy the last
finish like I got to point to the crowd
I saw a couple friends in the stands and
I pointed the other side and finally got
across the line and yeah ten nine - oh
nine oh nine the wall of sound has to be
unbelievable it's incredible stretch
yeah I mean I've I went to Boston for
they've got some shorter races that
weekend but the year before when it was
just pouring down rain and it was really
loud then so the next year when we had
really nice weather I couldn't believe
it you come out of the little tunnel and
you turn right on hair effort and it's
just it's like a rock concert mmm yeah
or it feels like a rock concert yeah
yeah and you are the rock star that's
yeah yeah hopefully you're still rockin
26 miles in and that morning it was
pouring rain right it was looked at it
wasn't gonna be a nice day
yeah and I was looking forward to that I
wanted the worst weather possible I
remember getting on the bus you got on
the bus to Boston I like 5:50 in the
morning
I remember texting my girlfriend like
it's raining so hard like this is so
awesome
I can't wait to get into this race and
both unfortunately unfortunately it
became super super nice all of a sudden
basically like 30 minutes before the
race started it was just perfect day
what are the mindset tactics that you
use I mean you talked about the jay-z
song and like what it what are the
things that you kind of rely upon to you
know meet those obstacles and those
barriers and push through you know the
pain I would say the biggest thing is
like meditation practice I've been
practicing for the better like part of
two years and I didn't start meditating
for running by any means but I think
anxiety brought you into that it was
yeah it was a way to combat anxiety and
sort of just deal with it in a more
healthy way but I think once you
practice it for long enough it kind of
becomes it kind of starts to permeate
other parts of your life and so being
present and in particular like the
strategy of noting where you just when
you realize you're distracted you just
say that's thinking and you can get back
in - mm-hmm focus a little bit more as
opposed to like ruminating on the fact
that you're thinking and then you're
pissed off that you're distracted and
that's just all more thinking if you can
just note it and let it go I think
that's one of the more helpful what is
this what is the daily practice of that
look like for you specifically
I just meditate 15 minutes in the
morning and then on good days I get in
like another ten in the evening do you
have a specific like practice you use a
nap yeah I use headspace oh you do yeah
yeah yeah cool and then like throughout
the day like are you does that give you
like that extra level of awareness when
you're when your mind drifts to like
bring it back
yeah I'd say I could be more focused in
my general life and I try to be mindful
but I would say the times when I feel
like the most at ease and the most
mindful or when I'm outside whether
that's running or walking the dog or
whatever yes for whatever reason being
outside helps a lot well running will
definitely bring you at the present
right yeah I would imagine your mind
still wander so you can you're always in
that when you're racing specifically or
training like to be always bringing it
back to like what's happening in the
moment yeah and I don't you know I don't
train with music I don't ever listen to
podcast when I run it's just me and my
thoughts and how dare you I know I'm
sorry rich I listen to you when I
stretch this interview is over yeah I
listen to you and I stretch and when I
Drive other it's all your podcast I
listen to them all all the time yeah
every single day it's one I've listened
to the call Brian Koppelman one 7 times
rich I feel better
yeah thank you we can keep going yeah
and I think just the more you can
practice having sort of like a quiet
mind the better whether that's formal
meditation practice or like taking 60
meters on a run interesting like what
I'm just gonna be really still until I
get back get past that tree or when you
get to like a turnaround point just
taking five seconds and feeling your
feet on the ground or feeling a win in
your face or appreciating the scenery do
you break it down into like when you're
really in the pain cave like okay I just
need to get right up to that next tree
or that next street lamp or I'm just
gonna focus on catching that one guy
who's right in front of me like you do
you do you like try to deconstruct it
and break it down into tiny little you
know bite-sized pieces no I just let it
all in you yeah I just say I can take
more that's the what I remind myself
it's like yeah I can go deeper I can
take more this is your this is your
superpower right like you're you have
you have a great amount of talent but
this ability to suffer and to show up
like late in the race like that seems
like these seem to be your strengths
yeah I think so yeah endure a lot yeah
yeah which isn't the coolest talent like
it would be way cooler if I could just
like be really smooth and have the same
results without hurting so badly but
being able to suffer and endure a lot
amongst the group of people who know how
to do that better than anyone is I would
say that that's a good distinguishing
talent I have yeah I'm I think as as
shitty as it is to be like yeah I can
endure a lot of pain and actually having
to endure it I'm grateful that I get
that opportunity and I kind of look
forward to it now
yeah what do you think is your weakness
or what's the thing that you you find
you
having at work on the most I'm probably
not as fluid as most people physically
and then I think mentally I I'm very
solid but I could come to practice with
more enthusiasm some days particularly
in like really hard training when the
workout isn't gonna be that hard and you
want to get whammed for it a guy
sometimes I come pretty flat
yeah and that's something I could do a
better job at uh-huh I'm aware that has
been remind you of that no he hasn't had
to usually I realize I'm kind of being a
drag ass on the warm-up when I'm pissed
off that I have to do it as opposed to
like really grateful and really excited
for the opportunity yeah yeah and and
are most of your workouts with teammates
or do you do solo training training like
what does it look like for you like
what's it take me through like a week of
training or what a typical day yeah I
mean most of our workouts are with
people so a typical day is like we meet
at 8:30 and go for a run and whether
that's an easy run or a workout usually
we're with a group before Boston since I
was the only one doing Boston and
Boston's like really specific I wasn't
really on the same schedule with anyone
I was doing a lot of stuff alone
but usually a lot of times at the very
least I'd be working out in the same
place as people so we could warm up
together and cool down and it wouldn't
be quite so lonely and after the run you
finished the run at 10 11 o'clock go
home usually do my like rehab then take
a nap usually and then in the evening we
go back out for four miles and that's
usually on my own and that's when I'll
take the dog out and we'll run together
and then afterwards sometimes get in a
sauna sometimes do stretching in core
twice a week we go to the weight room I
think it's you know it's pretty basic
yeah pretty basic yeah and how much of
it is on the track versus on trails or
roads I would prefer to never get on the
track I just I don't care for it
my body doesn't handle it that well it's
kind of boring I would prefer to go we
have this really nice workouts that are
kind of appropriate for that right yeah
they're your workouts that are that make
more sense on the track I would always
rather be on the road but almost all of
our easy running is on dirt roads we're
lucky and Flagstaff to be
surrounded by either national forests or
reservation so there there's a lot of
forest service roads for us to run on
which is really fun and then we're also
lucky to have like a few really good
road loops and lake mary road is where
we do most of our runs which is like I
think the road goes like 60 or 70 miles
but we have a 16 mile section that's
marked every quarter mile mm-hmm so we
do a ton of workouts on that mm-hmm
one of the things that that
distinguishes you from you know people
in your in your subculture is how
transparent you've been with all of your
training in addition to writing you know
this book inside of marathon where you
literally like this is what I get every
city they like to minut is detail you
share all your workouts on Strava you
know you write about it you make videos
like you're doing a lot of things to be
a complete open book about how you're
preparing and it's one thing for an
amateur athlete to do that and I think
you know a lot of people use Strava to
get the added the sort of accountability
with their friends etc but you don't see
that many elite athletes at their prime
sharing their workouts like you'll see
people after they retire and then
they're happy to do it but there's this
sense like well I don't want to you know
let people know we're on that
specifically because that might give
them a competitive advantage so walk me
through the decision of like being so
open about it and like why you why why
that's important to you
part of our our groups the Hogan is
really like mission statement is to
share a part of the journey so a part of
it is that I'm trying to do as good of a
job and my job as possible and live up
to my boss's standards and as a brand
ambassador that's right yes and do as
well as I can in representing Hoke only
part of it is also kind of like that
sort of creative stimulation like it's
fun to think of fun like interesting
clever ways to share your training and
on Strava I don't participate socially
really I just I put it out there
right just because I found that you read
the comments occasionally sometimes but
like there's never any I've never had a
like a constructive conversation or
anything on Strava people will either be
they'll either believe you did it or
they'll say that's wrong the wrong
activity type or they'll say that's bad
GPS data and so I just leave it be so I
just like alright this is what it was
this is what I did so you know that's
kind of changed a little bit but I think
it's like it's interesting and fun and
like kind of creatively difficult to
share your training in a way that's not
like a training log like I know that
inside a marathon is in its most basic
form it was always going to be a
training log but we were hoping it was
more like a journal which is more fun
and interesting and harder I think so
part of it is being a brand ambassador
part of it is is kind of trying to be
creative and use your brain a little bit
as opposed to just just running and like
posting a Ernest Hemingway quote on
Twitter like there's only so many times
you can do that before even yourself
gets bored well it takes a little bit of
confidence to say like I don't care
whether you see what I'm doing or not
yes I'm still gonna you know do it and
and you know you still have to do the
work right one of the things that's
interesting and scrolling through it
though is you know I think a lot of
people feel this pressure on Strava like
every workout has to be super epic and
you know if their pace isn't good they
won't upload it or whatever and there's
a lot of like workouts where it's like
you're running seven minute pace it's
like it's if you're six miles eight mile
it's like well you know a lot of people
can do that right and I think that's
really cool because it shows people the
reality of preparing for a marathon
which is there is a lot of like
basically just like casual running that
gets ya you know built into it yeah
absolutely
and I guess part it is then you'll throw
down some crazy workout that is fun too
but yeah that is finally yeah and also I
guess to your previous point like in
terms of my competitors it's like I
don't really care if they see what
they're doing because if they see what
I'm doing because
they're not gonna change it like I would
think less of something you follow some
of those people I don't know anyone else
doing this I don't know that any other
one else really does it so I would most
of them are my friends so I would follow
them right that's my no of course I
would think less of somebody if they
were like had a whole plan for a
marathon laid out and then they saw a
workout I did and they're like oh I know
actually I want to do that right and
frankly like that would not be smart no
and I've never had a marathon segment
that went a hundred percent smoothly
like if you want to read inside a
marathon and copy everything that I did
it's like okay I bombed a couple
workouts why don't you just blow up in a
few workouts there it's not like a it's
like an addition problem it's more like
like a soup or a recipe like you've got
to put a little bit here and put a
little bit there and maybe the something
isn't ripe or something isn't right and
you have to adjust so I don't really
think I don't think I've ever anyone has
ever said so okay that's what they're
doing we need to do that and then beat
me right yeah
well one of the things inside of
marathon that I think is so interesting
I mean really you know you can
characterize it as a as journals or as a
travel log but I look at at it as a case
study in the coach athlete relationship
yeah there's a big dive into how that
works and it's very inside baseball like
if you're training for a marathon like
read this book it will walk you through
you'll learn so much about how to do
that but I think every coach should read
it because it's really about like how
the coach responds to the athlete and
what that relation the the dynamic
nature of that relationship and there's
that one part in particular where you're
all keyed up for this workout I think
it's two times six miles or whatever and
then decides to discard it and there's a
whole you know kind of discussion about
that and it's super interesting to see
just how this is in a constantly
evolving thing it's not like here's your
plan this is what we're doing you know
it's like how are you feeling today like
all these micro adjustments that are
happening all the time and the
communication that's required on behalf
of both the athlete and the coach to
really produce the result that you're
both looking for yeah and
Ben does a great job of showing that in
the book and you can kind of see I guess
there's like two instances one where I
don't give him a lot of information
about how shitty I'm feeling and it was
like early in the book kinda in the
summer I'm just feeling really bad vomit
workout feel like dog [ __ ] and a workout
this should have been pretty easy and
then later in the segment when I'm
telling him it's like dude I'm like I'm
tired I'm beat right now then we
actually make a decision to to change a
workout and Ben is clued in it's kind of
it's small but you can see kind of the
negative side of maybe not communicating
enough with your coach is when I was
feeling really tired and terrible and he
was I didn't really tell him so I
thought this is my job I'm just supposed
to do what I'm told
but he knows yeah he I mean but I should
have been more I should have been more
yeah more open about how shitty I was
feeling but maybe I was maybe I was
nervous to tell him and I was feeling
shitty or maybe I didn't want to tell
him or whatever it was but yeah a couple
times in the summer when I was I should
have been more open right for the
further kind of uninitiated it's
interesting like there's so much heat
around this one workout it's like dude
it's just one workout right but there
are these like you're doing a ton of
running but there are these what these
particular workouts that pop up from
time to time at you know at at these
determined you know interval points that
are super important in your build and in
your prep mm-hmm that you kind of like
you just got to put in right so although
it was just one workout it was like a
super important one yeah I mean I still
ran great in New York oh yeah we put a
ton of importance on it but ultimately
like one workout didn't make or break
the segment any more than any other
workout didn't you know I could have
there could have any number of those
workouts I could have bombed and I
dropped out of what I would consider
kind of an important work out as well
and we just cancelled another one so you
could make the case that like as long as
you just do enough it'll be fine after
reading the book as well I think all the
importance is more like a projection as
opposed to sort of actual scientific
reality right right right
after working with them for a couple
years now what have you learned about
what makes a great coach like what's the
difference between a great coach or a
great coach athlete relationship versus
you know maybe some other types of
things that you've seen over the years I
think I don't miss I don't think this
all applies to just coach athlete but I
think it's probably trust and openness
like the more information I can give
been in a cohesive way is gonna let him
make better decisions and it's also I
have to trust him to make good decisions
as well like he just two weeks ago we
pulled out of a race that I was really
looking forward to because I got a
little bit of flu-like virus earlier in
the week and I just didn't look good but
I still wanted to go race and Ben said
that's a bad idea I think and I just I
have to trust him on that yeah because
if I don't trust him like what's the
point of even having a coach have you
ever gone to loggerheads with him though
what do you mean like had a conflict
where you felt really strongly about
doing something and he disagreed no I
don't think so I think if we ever did
that it would be like why do I even why
am I even working with Ben I'm just
going if we're just butting heads all
the time I really do trust him to make
good decisions and at some point like
his record has to speak for himself like
we've run well at three marathons myself
and him my teammate Kellen taylor has
run 224 she ran 226 again this year
we've had countless top 15 the World
Marathon Majors like he knows what he's
talking about
like I don't yeah it would be pretty
arrogant of me to presume that I can
just make a better decision than him
mm-hmm
when really like he's paid to make good
decisions and he's done a good job of it
for so long that it would be pretty
silly to be like yeah yeah you know what
I knew better actually but at some point
as you be as you get more and more
experienced you you you learn to know
yourself very well right like and I
would imagine there's a point at which
like you know what you need or you feel
you're gonna start to feel more strongly
about this that or the other thing and
there's a there's a there's sort of a
taking ownership thing that takes place
right and and learning how to like
navigate that with the coach
relationship I would imagine like you
see super elite experience
athletes who you know have disagreements
with their coaches maybe that's healthy
you know or it depends on the coach and
the athlete obviously but it's it's it
is interesting like you're really like
you just let him do his thing yeah yeah
yeah and he lets me do my thing like
right he's not there are a lot of times
have been a lot of times where I've been
feeling really good in a workout like
particularly my biggest one before
Boston we did just 16 miles steady and I
was feeling really really good and I
really really pushed and in general he
would be like okay like let's not go to
the well today like let's not leave the
race out here but he trusted me to feel
that I was feeling really good and to
make a good decision so he trusts me as
well
and there I do have a little bit of
autonomy but for the most part like I
just want to do what I'm told I just
like I like seeing what's on the paper
and I don't want to have the stress of
like trying to figure it out I just want
been I just trust been enough to where
it's like look if I do what Ben says and
I do it really well in the end result
you'll be worried I'll be where I need
to be that cool what do you think are
the the defining qualities of like the
ultimate marathon runner like what do
you what do you have to have in order to
succeed at your level at marathon
running I mean I think physically you
have to be very durable and you have to
get really really good at running
marathon pace I think that's the thing
that most people probably mess up they
probably do the wrong indicator workouts
so their workouts they'll do a workout
that is a really good indicator for
running a half marathon or running a 10k
on the track and be like look how fast I
ran in this it's like that's six by mile
isn't the same yeah so I think
physically it's being very durable and
getting really really good at running
about the pace you'll be running in a
marathon and that just doesn't mean just
getting really good at knowing what the
effort is but it means getting really
really efficient trying to not go not
burn too many calories too fast being
good at replacing them and then I think
mentally I think it's important to
expect to feel bad to let it in like you
have to make peace with the fact that
the
is really gonna hurt there's no way that
this won't be excruciating unless you're
just out there jogging yeah and I think
the sooner you make peace with that
the sooner like the easier it is when it
comes you're expecting that you're
looking forward to it as opposed to like
worrying about the last four miles and
dreading them that's just gonna make
them worse
I would imagine your mindfulness
practices and your mindset techniques
have helped you with that like to just
embrace like this is this is what it is
like and bring it on as opposed to being
afraid of it happening down the line
like oh and two more miles I'm really
gonna feel it yeah and when it does come
letting it in like it's there it's
coming along for the ride there's no way
the pain isn't gonna hurt but you can't
let it be the one that gets to make the
decisions you have to be right the one
in charge and if you let it in if you
acknowledge that it's gonna be there
then you got to be in charge of the pain
and it doesn't get to hold you back
maybe it keeps coming maybe it keeps
coming maybe it hurts a ton but if you
stay in front of it in terms of like I'm
just gonna let this really hurt I think
that's much more healthy than just
fearing it and letting it be the boss
right one of my favorite questions that
I like to ask elite athletes like
yourself like one of the things it's
that's unique about marathon running as
you go to these races and you compete
and all everyone at all that you know
holy polloi like everybody gets to
compete at the same time what have you
seen amateur runners do wrong like where
you're like doing come on you know like
yeah there's always these stories like
the day before the race or doing tempo
runs on the course or you know things
like that like what do you see all the
time that you and your buddies are like
don't they know that they should yeah
that's one thing I would say trying
something brand new the day before the
race it's like especially at these big
races like New York or power shoes yeah
like oh yeah I just got these new socks
they're supposed to be better like going
to the expo to buy shoes like you didn't
come with a pair of shoes right and then
spending all day on their feet and it's
like would you do this if you had to
work out
or the conversely people who just spend
the whole weekend in the hotel room it's
like you are in a big city like go enjoy
yourself a little bit just have like
what would you do the day before a
workout you might go for a short run and
go for a walk and go grab breakfast or
something like that do the same thing
it's fine like you people I guess the
thing that I see people do wrong is make
these races into like this huge like
special thing that is not the same as
how they prepared right like no you
you're ready you're prepared do the same
thing you would have done normally like
this doesn't have to be you don't have
to get out of your rhythm just because
now you're in Boylston you know but
there's all this second-guessing yeah
last-minute adjustments and I think that
comes from fear insecurity for the ass
part I think so yeah I think just I
think people probably get in their own
way a little bit too much as opposed to
just you know what I'm hearing boils in
Boston I want to appreciate I want to
have a little bit fun this weekend I
want to take in the marathon atmosphere
but it's like you've done this a ton of
times you know you've if you've trained
well you should kind of know what's
coming and if you qualified for Boston
yeah you kind of know what to do yeah
right mm-hmm
I just get out of your own way just go
have go out there and have fun you know
it's supposed to be fun yeah you don't
have to worry about it don't have to
stress about it and frankly like people
put all this pressure on themselves and
really it's not like that important like
I know that even for me like I know this
is my job and this is how I make money
but if I go out in the trials and like I
get sixth or I run three hours or
something like that it's like the people
who love me are still gonna love me
uh-huh
the peep my friends are still gonna be
my friend it's like I'm a hundred
percent sure my girlfriend won't dump me
if I run bad at the trials mmm and if
all that if I I'm so it's really I'm
free to take big chances I'm free to go
out there and just run as hard as I can
and whatever those results are will be
fine because the things that are really
important the people that I care about
will still be there right you got
yourself into like a little bit of hot
water when you said this thing of like
if you were given the choice of running
under two hours or giving up burritos
for the rest of your life that you would
you would you would stick with the
burritos and that caused a lot of
discussion yeah I mean I know your
commitment yeah I'm sport I made a joke
yeah you know yeah people like you know
on these forums you know they'll take
this stuff seriously yeah I mean I don't
like I don't know what else do you want
me to do thank you well I do I like look
I'm living my life like your happiness
is important and I like speaking of like
making a joke I love like in the
beginning of the book you cut you open
it up by saying I've always wanted to be
the subject of a book or a documentary
yeah yeah this kind of like hilariously
like self-mocking narcissistic you know
like rant that is I thought was
hilarious like thank you you know and
but I think what I see I hear the same
tone in that and the joke that you made
yeah I try not to take myself too
seriously by all means like I know that
the reason I have a platform is pretty
stupid like I can run pretty fast much
changing the world or like writing
important books or anything like that
like I'm a guy you can put one foot in
front of the other pretty quickly for a
long period of time like I should have
some fun and I should make fun of myself
a little bit yeah and now I appreciate
that yeah what do you make of all that
like we're in an interesting time and
running right now like there's some
really cool kind of storytelling
happening and and the running world like
outside of just elite marathoning has
really exploded with the expansion of
ultra running and like the breaking to
project and and you know you see people
crossing over from like like what
Walmsley he's doing like you know going
from western states and you know half
marathon and marathon and all that kind
of stuff like how do you think about how
you you know somebody who's into movies
who's into storytelling who's written a
book like how do you think about
storytelling and running and how you
connect with the public about what it is
that you do yeah and I would extend the
storytelling like explosion kind of
Desai chling as well and I think in
running we're we're behind cycling we
can do a better job you see especially
this education first team they've got
sending people diesel
her native races like the dirty cans
Leadville 100 and I think one of the
huge powers in that in running is
there's a lot of ways now to have fun
with it
you see these unsanctioned races like
the speed project where there's just
unsanctioned three and a 40 mile race
and because these things exist and we're
at a place especially with social media
and Twitter and Instagram there's a
medium for people to share these stories
really easily and really excessively you
don't need like multi-million dollar
budgets and you don't need to put this
out on HBO or on Sunday it's like you
can just make it and then put it on the
Internet
I think the the storytellers have done a
really good job of finding these niches
of people who are just having fun and we
in the elite world need to take a cue
from them the storytellers in who are
sharing documentaries about the speed
project or Berkeley marathon write work
and figure out ways to make what we're
doing interesting and fun and I think
there are some there are some
interesting or some good examples of
that
I hope inside a marathon is one of them
you know we really tried hard and have
worked really hard to make something
that we're proud of but I think a lot of
it comes down to initiative and I don't
necessarily know if there's enough
initiative in my opinion from the elite
athletes to like go out and make it you
can't just wait and rely on outside
sources to come and make the project you
have to know you have to take your own
ability for that yourself you've been
doing that you make these YouTube videos
and I like I feel like you've really
taken that mantle and and and embraced
it and I think it's I think it's
important as a professional athlete and
as a sponsored athlete and brand
ambassador like this is part of your job
now right to like story tell because I
think it's easy for the general public
to look at somebody like yourself or or
Asha Lane or a DES and just feel like I
can't relate to these people like
they're just cyborgs but that's not the
case they're you're all human beings and
you know you're down at the coffee shop
eating a burrito and working on a book
and you're human being and you have
stories to tell and there's a lot of
who you are that's incredibly relatable
and the more that the general public can
kind of connect with your journey the
more invested they are in your success
and ultimately the more connected they
are to the sport absolutely I agree I
mean I think you said it much better
than I did previously there so let's
just take your answer yeah well you dumb
it over my voice and if I write it out
I'll just restate it I think it's you
know in you are seeing more and more of
it like it like like one jorgensen now
is doing this vlogging you know I think
that's really cool and I just think more
and more that's that's part of the job
you know and I think more athlete you're
gonna see more athletes doing it but
it's it's like an added expense to and
it's like who wants somebody following
them around with a camera all the time
like you're trying to you know be your
very best and yet when you put this book
together there's incredible photographs
from like all of your workouts on
obviously you had you know you had the
forethought to like have a photographer
therefore all these sessions so that you
could document it and share it
yeah well we were very lucky that Ben's
wife Jen uh-huh she is she was a star
she also did all the formatting for it
and put my book kind of together she was
very very talented of that so we were
lucky to have that I don't necessarily
know if we would have had the budget
necessarily to have someone do it if we
had to pay so much time publish it Yeah
right and that was kind of like we we
never planned on like making this a
financial thing like we were just like
this would be really cool if it existed
and we would be into this this will be
fun to make and so it just kind of made
the most sense it's like let's just do
it exactly how we want to do it and
let's just put it out and then you could
put it out you could also put it out
really quickly yeah so did it come out
like right after New York yeah I think
we got it out by December 20th Wow so
really New York was like November 4th so
less than two months and that included
writing the last three chapters all that
it's all the epilogues picking the
pictures and then we had a little
trouble finding like a printer that we
could get it printed you know for a
reasonable price yeah that's the thing
you have to become this project manager
yeah
all this kind of stuff which I did not
expect when we first started I was just
like yeah we're just gonna write and
there'll be pictures and then it'll be
out it'll just put it out in the end you
have to pay for the printing yeah
before anyone buys it yeah and now I
mean we've since Boston we we've added
another chapter we're gonna release a
second edition coming out soon so it's
still kind of turning into a little bit
more of a living document and Ben and I
both hope to do a future one hopefully
if I make the Olympics and you won for
the Olympics yes becomes a series
absolutely and emotionally I just want
to do it so I can call it inside a
marathon to Tokyo Swift yeah and I'm
sure that won't be the official name but
that's why we're exclusive to it or
Tokyo draft Tokyo draft that's a good
one too yeah one of the two yeah so
depending upon how the race goes
absolutely yeah so yeah I mean it was
like really fun and I think that's
something that kind of people just think
about how hard it's gonna be when
they're thinking about telling a story
and it's actually really fun too there's
some stuff that I didn't care for like
editing isn't my favorite or like I like
all the footnotes
yeah the footing but like riding the
footnotes were my favorite that was that
was great
it was fun to come up with jokes yeah so
much of the conversation over the last
year or two when it comes to marathoning
in America has been about the women like
we've seen this resurgence of the
prominence of American women marathoners
which has been really cool to see but
not a lot of talk about the dudes and
even in the coverage it's like it's
about the women which is like an awesome
thing yeah but now here we are we have
you and like you're on your you're like
you've kind of emerged as this face and
voice of American marathon running so
you know how do you like take stock of
American marathon running right now
versus what it was a couple years ago I
mean I think first of all the coverage
has deservedly bit on the women yeah
they've been competing at a higher level
des inch lane both majors you know we've
got big stars in Molly huddle and Emily
Sisson my teammate kelan Steph Bruce and
other one my teammates they've both been
running at a level
is frankly higher internationally than
what we men have been doing so I'm not
begrudging the fact that we weren't we
weren't covered as heavily as the women
I think that's great and I also think
there's room to cover the women a lot
more there's still races every year that
World Marathon Majors that don't start
the women ahead so the coverage of the
women is almost unwatchable they're just
buried back behind Chicago did it last
year and we missed one of the great
races ever so I think there's still a
lot of opportunity to share women's
running better that being said I guess
like I think American men's run
marathoning has always been pretty good
I think but the times haven't
necessarily reflected that that's kind
of what I meant when I said there was
this disconnect where everyone kind of
thought good and fast were the same and
if you just want to take speed we're the
American men are you know this year so
far we've had to 209 s myself and Jared
Ward mm-hmm and that's about eight
minutes slower than Eliot khashoggi
right record a whole battery oh yeah
staffer Kensu mm-hmm you know can make
mincemeat of that yeah but in terms of
running well and placing high I think
American men's marathoning is actually
doing pretty well and has been doing
pretty well we've finished high at
Boston's New York's we've had people on
the podium we've been if you want to say
like champion championship racing
scenarios where there's not rabbits and
there's not just all right go out see
who can run the fastest probably the
third or fourth best country in the
world behind Kenya and Ethiopia and
maybe you could put like a Uganda or
Eritrea in front of us so I think we've
been doing well but not necessarily in a
way that's tangible nobody really knows
what's sixth or seventh in New York is
especially when you're six minutes
behind the leader um but that's just
kind of my take I'm sure that somebody
on let's run will hear this podcast and
get mad at me again for it [ __ ] so so
the fastest Ryan Hall still the fastest
no [ __ ] yeah sorry he so he's run Ryan's
from the
fastest-ever marathon by an American he
ran it was it I think was 204 to a 458
at Boston and then the American record
is 205 thirtysomething by a guy named
khalid khannouchi from like 2005 and
then we've had Galen Dathan yeah
we've had people running in the meb yeah
running in the 207's 208 right and so
your your lo 209 is like 11th on that
pecking yeah right 11th all-time so
heading into trials you got to get for a
second or third to make the team who who
are you
I know you're just thinking about your
own race but who are the other people to
watch in your opinion right now I think
over the last few years a guy named
Galen Rupp has been on paper probably
the best American marathoner he's run
206 or something in the one Chicago 2nd
in Boston so on paper he's very good and
should be the favorite probably but
there's also a good friend of mine Jared
Ward who finished right ahead of me in
New York and then seven right behind me
in Boston how much training were you
guys doing together he was in Flagstaff
for about a week so we went on a few
easy runs and then one really big
workout before New York and then I
haven't I didn't really get training
with him since but he's your dude he's a
guy yeah I really like Jared and we've
competed against each other since
college because he went to BYU I went to
University of Portland and they're in
the same conference so been racing each
other a lot usually he's beating me yeah
but I'm excited to kind of meet boss I
got him in Boston yeah I got the better
PR so I own him now if you're listening
Jared I own you keep that in mind but
we've got a good group of other really
talented runners shadrach be watt has
been top three at Boston Chris Derek
unfortunately just broke his ankle but
he's very talented as well Dathan Ritson
Hein has run 207 so I think those are
those guys and a lot of others
should be should be ready to go and in
good format the trials so right so
trials are into February yep every time
Atlanta mm-hmm and how is that course
breakdown
yeah gonna be really hilly yeah it looks
like it'll be about 1,300 feet of gain
and loss over the course of the race so
it's gonna be three eight mile loops and
I think that favors me I'm here to race
really hard and I think the lack of
rhythm kind of is right up my alley
where it's just gonna be she's gonna be
really really hard and I think that
suits me pretty well how are you gonna
knock it injured how I guess not get
injured yeah well I've been I've been
lucky to be pretty durable and I think
or I go see a I got a massage every week
I we have good - good Kairos I think
that's one of the things that a lot of
amateur runners could do better
mm-hmm is you put all this money and
time into training and stuff and then as
soon as something like pops up you're
like I'll just figure it out you know
like my ankle hurts I'll just I'll just
figure it I was like I don't know find
like a cairo find a massage therapist
find a physical therapist that you can
go see I gave up you're gonna buy three
and the dollar pair of shoes but you
won't spend 60 or 80 bucks to go see a
professional who's gonna give you
exercises and Rehab and help you to be
healthy so I do that I'm a big believer
in that
so Cairo it you get like your back crack
and you do decompression or what does
that look like specifically yeah a lot
of it's a RT Active Release therapy so
painful yeah
the dry needling our tire is a dry
needle certified and you know there's
sometimes it's scraping sometimes it's
there yeah cupping no they they haven't
ever cupped me but I mean if they ever
want to trust them you gotta get on the
cup I get on the cupping okay yeah it's
I would say they probably look more like
PT than a typical Cairo it's not a ton
of like back cracking spine stuff it's a
lot more wherever you're kind of injured
and trying to figure out the root cause
that and what is the other aspect of
recovery look like for you like you use
the foam rolling and like the key of the
Norma tech boots and what does that
entail yeah I do have the Norma tech
boots try to film roll a lot and just
generally do the rehab that the colors
give us and we also go we do strength
work twice a week in the gym and there's
like Olympic lifts like deadlifts squats
that kind right and that's not only
performance-enhancing but it's also
rehab as well
right but I mean honestly like I can sit
here and talk about all the little tiny
things that I do for recovery but really
like sleep this is the biggest one I try
to take a nap pretty regularly try to
have good sleep hygiene with like not
doing stuff in my bed other than
sleeping and yeah and try to go to bed a
reasonable hour wake up get right out of
bed that kind of thing just regular
sleep stuff nothing it's not too special
yeah like what's your special morning
yeah no just get up and just you wake up
and you get up and drink coffee that's
good morning routine yeah
is is the US Olympic Committee if they
like invited you up to Colorado Springs
is there any of that kind of stuff going
on like I know in swimming like they'll
do training camps and they'll bring like
the top people in for you know little
week-long sessions and things like that
does it is that does that happen in
marathon running or not so much the
Olympic Committee's more hands-off I
think and run and in most sports and the
runnings lot it's more corporate I think
it's more well funded in the sense that
more groups have the resources we don't
necessarily need to go through the USOC
uh-huh and so what's the one thing if
there is anything that you're really
focused on working on now that you
weren't like in your lead-up to Boston
like is there anything like this is the
one thing I really want to master that I
feel like was holding me back before or
is it just I'm doing the same thing I
mean the training has changed I guess
now since I'm not getting ready for a
marathon but in terms of like
big-picture stuff I just want to do the
same stuff I want to just I don't need
to feel like I need to do extra I don't
need to go back to the drawing board I
just want to do the same stuff that got
me really really ready for Boston and I
don't want to like have this sort of
neuroticism where it's like I need to do
more I need to do more and you do more
do you have a goal time in mind know the
course is gonna be too hard I just wanna
be pop top three and what is the course
like in Tokyo it will be pretty flat but
it will be really really hot humid
mm-hmm I think this year on the day it
was we were supposed to have the
marathon like if it had been this year
it was well into the 90s with 90%
humidity that's really high yeah it'll
be brutal yeah yeah do you do any like
you go train in certain places to
acclimate to that I mean cuz you know
flag stuff super dry yeah you have the
altitude but it's a completely different
climate I think for the Olympics we
probably will whether that's like
Houston or Hawaii or maybe even going to
like Okinawa or something like that
we haven't we're trying to make the team
first so we haven't discussed that but
in general we're capable like we have us
kind of a sauna protocol if we're going
to a really hot climate where we'll just
sauna for you know fifteen to thirty
minutes like ten times in the three
weeks leading up to the race and that
will kind of help and overdressing and
stuff like that so you don't put the
treadmill in the sauna I haven't done
that no I've heard of people doing that
people for badwater yeah train for
battle water I don't never run on the
treadmill either I would I don't care
for the treadmill so I just rather go
outside so we just we just found the
title for the podcast yeah I don't care
for the treadmill yeah in in getting
ready for all what was the question I
wanted to ask I just had a brain fart
I had it all chambered and everything
there's about the treadmill probably no
I know what it was yeah so we could just
spend like a half an hour on the
treadmill you seem like somebody whose
motivation is really internally
generated it's not like hey I need to
beat this guy or I need to be on this
podium or to win like this is about you
versus you mm-hmm
is that fair yeah absolutely and it
wasn't always like that a lot of it was
sort of like like almost petty like man
I want to [ __ ] beat this guy but I
think in [ __ ] oh yeah then there was a
little of that in the book too huh but
in 20 maybe 2017 2016 maybe no it'd been
I ran the Houston half marathon and it's
usually really good weather really fast
course really flat this one year which
is like soupy
we weren't gonna run fast and it got
really hard I like 10 miles and I threw
myself a little pity party
like I wasn't running as fast as I
wanted to I wasn't beating the guys I
wanted to and I was like this is
[ __ ] I'm this is stupid I don't
wanna do this anymore I want to drop out
and I kind of jog which into the finish
and it wasn't a good time and I finished
a lot lower than I've should have
finished and I kind of like looked at
that race and I was like I probably
can't this probably isn't a sustainable
form of motivation being like I have to
beat these people I need to figure out a
more like sustainable way to push myself
and then like 2 weeks later with the
u.s. cross country championships in Bend
Oregon and it was snowy it was bad
weather it was really muddy course and
this was to qualify to go to the World
Championships and top six go I was in
the lead group there was like seven of
us going into the last 2k and down this
big hill I kind of fell and slipped and
I lost 20 meters or something
hammered as hard as I could try to get
back onto the group and I fell again on
a corner and all of a sudden like
they're like 70 80 meters ahead I'm just
watching the last world cross country
spot go away from me and I kind of was
like look maybe that's gone today but I
can still hurt as much as I possibly can
I can go as hard as I possibly can and
that was probably the most I've ever
heard in a race was the last K I just
absolutely dug deep and ripped as hard
as I could and I probably wasn't running
that fast but I was going as hard as I
could go and I was really really proud
of that race because I wasn't worried
about what other people were doing I did
the thing that I wanted to do which was
do the best that I could do on that day
and I've kind of made peace with the
fact that sometimes I'm gonna run as
well as I can possibly run and I'm gonna
get beat I'm not the most talented best
runner in the world but and I can't
control who else comes to the line or
the fitness that they're in or or any of
those extrinsic factors but I can
control how well or how hard I go today
and maybe I have a mediocre day and I'm
trying to turn that into a good day
maybe I have a good day like I had in
Boston I'm trying to turn that into a
great day so I don't know that's kind of
been that's kind of how I got to this
point yeah I mean I like that you know
that is the sustainable fuel that you
need the anger and the the sort of lower
emotions might get you to a certain
place but ultimately it's not gonna
serve you over the course of a career
yeah we got to find it different seat
for that for that drive but were you
always like super competitive when you
were a kid yeah like we saw you know
like what what was it like growing up
like where does that come from I don't
really know I mean I was just
competitive right off the bat maybe it
was just like my parents I'm good at
this
yeah it's gonna win yeah my parents
started since my sister and I in sports
really young and it was just like I
realized like it's really fun to be good
at something and when you kind of butt
up against that and you're young a lot
of it is based on how like much do you
want it like talent and training when
you're like 12 years old doesn't have as
much to do with it is like you know what
I'm just gonna run harder I'm just gonna
go deeper today or your high school had
a pretty good program we date yeah yeah
we were state champs my sophomore year
and then a second place my junior year
and we'd were well good did well are my
freshman year as well so huh-huh wait a
good team and your sister still run no
she doesn't
she was never a runner she did like
soccer and basketball - yeah parents
still together yep
yeah that's nice yeah it's great when
you look back on you know you're still
at the beginning of your career really
but would you like thinking back to that
kid in high school you know running
cross-country could you have predicted
or imagined that you'd be in this
situation I probably imagined I'd be
better yeah realistically I'm sure like
when I would love the honesty of that
you know when I was logging miles in we
rage I probably have mana
I probably assumed I'd have three gold
medals and a world record by now but so
most about a frustrating decade there at
times probably I think I probably like I
got to college and my first year I
didn't handle the freedom and easy
access to beer all that well and I think
probably I realigned my expectations and
I've been working back to like right the
confidence I guess
uh-huh since then and so you're behind
schedule yeah really a realistic way
yeah
okay I'm gonna have to make all three of
these next Olympic teams win gold medals
just to impress high school Scott well
it's good that you're 27 yeah you got a
coach that believes in you yeah
absolutely
what would you what would you tell that
youngster like that sixteen-year-old kid
I would say I'd probably tell him make
sure it's always fun and find ways to
keep it fun mm-hmm because at certain
points in college like especially that
first year when I was running like
garbage because I was out until 2:00
a.m. three times a week and you know
drinking too much and eating like [ __ ]
it wasn't fun because it's not that fun
to wake up and like be hungover and go
for a long run and I think I kind of
lost sight of the fact that like this is
a sport this is a game it's supposed to
be fun and it took me a little while to
maybe find that again so it's fun for
the most part but there's got to be days
where you're like I can't I don't want
to get out of bed today yeah but so what
do you how do you talk your way through
that because I think like I'm trying to
root it in the experience of a listener
who's like you know maybe training for
their first marathon and is struggling
with you know motivation or the kind of
strategies that somebody like yourself
might employ to get over those humps
yeah I mean I think for most people what
they would say that going for a run is
the best part of their day you know even
if it's not every day but I try to keep
that in mind - it's like I get to do to
do it the best part of most people's day
for my job and even if there are things
that I don't really like it's like it's
part of being an adult it's like doing
aspects of your job that you don't
necessarily like and when I really think
about it it's like I got a pretty sweet
gig here like the worst part of my day
is doing hamstring rehab or something
like that you know so I guess like for
the average runner who's probably
getting up at 6 you know which is not
something I do get or getting up early
and going straight out the door and
they've got all these other
responsibilities so making sure it stays
it's like I get to instead of a half -
right sometimes easier said than done
absolutely I mean you have some crazy
workout yeah over you I mean I'm not you
know I don't want to sit here and say
like I'm some
Zen Buddha who always appreciates the
gratitude it's like no I have days where
I don't want to do [ __ ] mm-hmm I just
want to write like sit at home or I want
to go do something not running but
trying to remember that this is this is
a sweet thing I got to do a little extra
and II put a column on those days yeah
absolutely yeah definitely yeah and how
do you keep the Olympic dream in
perspective because that that looms so
heavy right like it's it's just such a a
massively ambitious thing and you know
the dream of a lifetime and I would
imagine it it would be easy for it to
kind of you know infect you and not a
good way unless you're able to like kind
of you know keep it in check yeah I try
not to deal with it too much like that
as like an end you know I have gotten to
this point where ever I got to the point
where I got to in Boston because I
wasn't thinking about like I have to win
Boston nor do I think I have to make the
Olympic team I'm just gonna prepare as
well as I can I'm gonna try to focus on
doing the best I can do today on this
thing and then I have faith that if I do
well at the things that I need to do now
the end will be there and I am willing
to bet on myself that I'll be tough
enough and strong enough and fit enough
to to accomplish things I don't need to
do I don't need to like have some huge
carrot Olympic ratings down the road do
you do any visualization techniques like
when you're getting ready for a big race
you've been on the course at Boston you
know every turn or whatever do you like
walk yourself through it mentally like
what do you do before you line up on the
starting line and you know in that kind
of sense
I let myself visualize when I'm on runs
usually like thinking about the last few
miles and imagine just feeling not
imagine feeling really good but imagine
running really well I think it's
important to acknowledge that this is
really gonna hurt like it's not helpful
to visualize it not hurting because it's
gonna hurt so I let myself think in the
race or like it while I'm on runs I'm
imagine or I imagine the race yeah yeah
and then once I get to the line it's
really a matter of like I mean not
letting myself write the store
before I before it happens you know it's
just I just want to be where I'm at and
that's kind of what I do when I'm on the
line I try to you know in mindfulness
it's called like grounding usually where
you just focus on your feet touching the
ground that's kind of what I do usually
before races I don't need to get hyped
up I don't need to get like out of my
head or whatever I just want to be where
I am right yeah I think that's really
important I mean one of the things you
hear with marathon runners or ultra
distance athletes there are moments
where you know it's not going well and
it's easy to just not just throw a pity
party but just think well I'm done you
know but to stay ground it and present
with what you're doing and with
experience understanding that just
because you feel lousy now like five
minutes from now you might feel great
feeling great these things change
absolutely mm-hmm yeah I think it's Amy
Craig had a really good quote about this
she's a wonderful marathoner but she
said I know I'm gonna have good miles
and I know I'm gonna have bad miles and
I don't know what order they're gonna
come in mmm and sometimes I remind
myself of that and I think another thing
that happens a lot at least to me it's
like when I'm feeling bad when I feel
like I'm having a bad mile if I actually
check-in if I'm actually like okay how
do I actually feel it's really not that
bad it's probably like my mind's
projection that I'm supposed to be
feeling bad so being present and like
actually checking in with how your legs
feel right make you feel better that's
interesting yeah distinguishing between
how you actually feel and the story that
you're telling yourself yeah how you
feel which is probably the worst right
worse than you actually yeah like in
Boston for example like we got through
the halfway mark and I think I was 104
40 and the fastest would ever come
through the half-marathon market a
marathon was like one I was six 12 or
something like that and so I think my
mind was like oh like oh [ __ ] you're
wearing an uncharted territory here like
we're 90 seconds under pace and they
were like you better they're telling my
likes like you better slow down when I
actually felt when my legs felt and like
checked in with my body it's like no
like if I'm fine I'm okay like this I
just didn't expect him to hurt and you
have to kind of I'm expecting to feel
shitty I'm expecting that this is too
fast but in actuality I'm not feeling
bad yeah and pretty close to even
splitting it yeah a negative split I
bought did you are you negative yeah I
was 104 4104 29 Wow which is hard
because I'm hard but the best more
marathon performances are pretty even
right in terms of first and first and
backhouse yeah I mean in terms of speed
yeah if you're gonna run like the
fastest you could run you would want it
to be even but the best performance is
in terms of like winning races are
almost all negative split okay because
you generally especially at races like
Boston New York and Chicago like there
are big moves at the end mm-hmm where
people will run be running right having
really really fast miles yeah to break
the race open what do you think about
Quinn Jorgensen's Proclamation about
making the Olympic team you know I have
yeah podcast recently yeah I listened to
that but I mean some you know it's a
bold statement and one of the things I
asked her was like you know what was
that like after scent you know like sir
okay you win the gold medal and
triathlon you retire and then you make
this announcement and then you show up
at the our men like how and how'd that
go right like how are you received and
seems like people were happy to receive
her by her account but I'm interested in
how the marathon world is kind of what
the reception is yeah so I guess when I
first heard she said okay I'm gonna go
win the gold medal I was kind of like
yeah all right [ __ ] Quinn like come
on like let's be real here let's be I
kind of thought it was like too brash
and too
I was too much I think was my initial
reaction and then I was like well like
why do I think that like she has every
right to have whatever goal she wants to
have and I think it's great that she's
sharing it like I think my I should have
taken a second before I was like before
in my head I was like now [ __ ] that
that's a that's a stupid thing to say
because in real reality it's like I kind
of admire admire her for a having the
highest goal as possible and B being
open and honest I like being afraid to
just say that yeah knowing then it will
you know there's gonna be some people
that aren't gonna receive it so well
yeah like I should have I should have
taken a beat and then
well good on her you know but I admit
that I didn't at first yeah well it'll
be exciting to watch yeah I you know I
hope she's I know she has had some
injury issues I hope she's healthy and
ready to go on the line I think she's
making her way back so is that is it
trials are the women and the men running
like the same weekend or how does that
work yeah well run on the same day day
we actually just got an email about this
I think it's the current plan right now
the men will start at 12:03 on February
29th the women will start 20 minutes
later so that we're not lapping them mmm
and it'll be three eight mile loops and
then a 2.2 mile stretch out of the loop
to finish Wow
so on the course at the same time yeah
but interesting they the USATF has
assured us that we shouldn't be the men
shouldn't be lapping women until the
third lap and it should be spread out
enough where it won't be like trying to
navigate huge groups and I think the top
women will be probably catching the top
men or the sorry though the stragglers
on the men's side at some point as well
because at the moment I think like 700
people have qualified for the Olympic
Trials mm-hmm so it'll be a huge event
and is it strictly like four second or
third or there are other like weird
things that happen you know as you see
in other sports yes so for the u.s. it
was so convoluted super super convoluted
until maybe like five weeks ago where
there was like an a standard and then
there was a point system and it was
gonna be like you're not even people in
the sport could explain how it was gonna
work
and luckily the US ATF lobbied the IWF
which is the governing body of sports
the sport to make the Olympic Trials
like a gold label event and to what that
means shortcut is that the top three
across the line will make the team they
will achieve the standard and be
eligible for the Olympics in the US ATF
will just have to submit their names the
top three will go from the trials and
that's it like if somebody else two
weeks later it's some other marathon run
some easy no I'm or somebody gets
injured
there's something out I mean that's why
it's been done in swimming forever I'm
like it's just very like there's no
other it's just your first or second or
that's it yeah and I think there's some
there's some wiggle room with injuries
you can kind of after before a certain
date but yeah it's been like that for
the marathon for a really long time the
standards were slow enough where if you
won the Olympic Trials or you were top
three at the Olympic Trials you had the
standard and that was awesome it made
for great events and great just a really
cool dramatic thing there was a finality
and it was kind of in danger for a
little while but luckily that's not the
case yeah
so you make the team it's also I feel
like the timing is really good to like
it gives you plenty of time to bill to
take a break and then build back up yeah
in swimming they keep it's like peril
perilously close to the actual game so
it's always this weird science
experiment of like do you train hard or
you maintain like but here being an end
of February like you have a nice block
after that yeah and on the track it's
more similar to swimming where the
Olympic Trials will be in the summer
uh-huh and then the people who make the
team will go to the Olympics later that
summer so I think for shorter distances
that's probably good because you don't
have to like end your season necessarily
even if the race is a 10k like you're
probably pretty beat up and maybe you
feel bad for a few days but you can come
back and still be fit with a marathon
that's not really an option like you
couldn't they couldn't have it the
marathon in like May or even you know
later like July yeah there's no like
four weeks later you go awful it would
be terrible yeah so it kind of you know
it's a little bit event-specific
in that regard right all right we got to
wind this down in a minute here okay one
of the things I wanted to give you the
opportunity to talk about is just you
know now that like you're in the media a
little bit more like is there anything
that you think people get wrong about
you or is there a narrative out there
that you feel like they don't understand
what I'm trying to do here like I just
want to give you the opportunity to like
correct the record if there's anything
out there where you think people are
misunderstanding you or marathon running
for that matter yeah many thing we
talked about the difference between like
what good is and what fast is and how
those aren't necessarily a hundred
percent the same thing that's kind of
been the thing I've probably gotten the
most [ __ ] for online people chastising
my opinion that good can be finishing
high and not just running fast like
general mean like harkening back to some
imaginary Golden Age of American
Marathon exactly actually didn't exist
exactly 100 percent correct yeah if
somebody wants to go through the history
books and show me an era where people
were running sub 210 every single time
out I would be happy to hear about it I
don't think it exists other than that I
think I've done a pretty good job of
like telling my own story and
communicating the messages that I
personally wanted to communicate and so
I've just done it myself
as opposed to like letting other people
get it wrong yeah but yeah all right the
only thing I would say and I know this
is gonna be a shock to other people is I
don't actually only eat burritos I know
we didn't talk a ton about burritos but
I've got this like reputation online for
eating a lot of burritos you created
that narrative absolutely I'm not a
person I did but I think some people
think that's the only thing I eat and I
would like to go on the record as saying
I only mostly eat burritos there are
other aspects only mostly are you mostly
only know the main food food how many
burritos a week I mean on a good week
like six yeah on a bad week one - I'm
with you are so good I probably eat that
many burritos yeah home burritos they're
all perfect yeah yeah I have a couple
burrito recommendations okay you're in
LA absolutely gonna be where are you
guys going after this are you gonna be
on the west side I think we're going
back towards Ontario and then by LAX
yeah so hit holy guacamole
holy guacamole Street in Santa Monica
that's kind of favorite every time I go
to LAX or I fly in LAX and I'm making my
way back home I always drop in there
holy walk it's just a little
hole-in-the-wall place they make it good
it's pretty good are there does the menu
have pictures no oh I like you and you
and I like you know I mean I'll I like
there's a lot of like that just the the
old-school food trucks not the fancy
ones that park at construction sites and
stuff like that that's really good yeah
absolutely yeah yeah so how I guess I
had to get the burrito plugin yeah sorry
and all right final question what's the
movie or your most anticipating right
now let's see it like that's coming out
yeah man I I'm upset that I don't
remember the name what's the name of the
movie that's coming out the Lenawee
throat sunny sunny in something it's got
Michael Kiwanuka KITT I don't think
that's that's his name not named Michael
Kiwanuka Michael he was in widows and he
was in get out oh right yeah and then I
don't know the woman it's I'm interested
to see that one and I just watched the
summer has been a good movie summer we
had Once Upon a Time in Hollywood we had
Hobson Shaw and we had John Waite three
so I had a really good summer of yes
yeah I have a good John Waite three
story okay the perfect house absolutely
all right cool well I'm so excited for
Olympic Trials I can't wait to watch you
and I'm cheering for you you're one of
the good guys man and I'm excited to see
what you're gonna do it's super exciting
so that's the luck to you thank you so
much rich and thanks for having me yeah
and once you make the Olympic team and
go to Tokyo and all that come back and
tell us about it will you sounds good
I'll just try to live up to the image I
had it myself in high school yeah we can
come talk to me yeah please do that in
the meantime everybody check out inside
a marathon it's not on Amazon right like
you got to get it to your website yes
the website Scott mumble calm we should
have Amazon well because they would make
us charge like $40 for it okay but we
want to we're doing it through our own
website inside a marathon second edition
should be coming out soon I don't know
when this podcast will drop hopefully
we'll have the book out by then and
we'll have an e-version as well oh cool
so awesome yeah audio book audio book no
not an audio book I'm not doing that
that's too long unless we can get Morgan
Freeman to Riga that on it well now
you're a podcaster okay we could do it
do that yeah you could bring in like
guests people to like mimic your voice
yes one person buddy yeah if if we get
there's like twenty two chapters if 22
people volunteer you can all read one
chapter that's fine with me all right
you should do that okay in the meantime
Scott fog will calm
at s fobs on Instagram yep and that's
got fobs on Twitter right cool man
thanks brother thank you
peace peace good luck
[Music]